there was
uh this washington post article from
a few days ago so i could just show my
screen very briefly so people can see
what we're talking about biden selects
transgender doctor
rachel levine as assistant health
secretary
and i'm going to read just the second
paragraph before
giving my screen back dr rachel levine
this is
biden's words in a statement dr rachel
levine will bring the study leadership
and essential expertise we need to get
people through this pandemic
no matter their zip code race religion
sexual orientation
gender identity or disability and meet
the public health needs of our country
in this critical moment and beyond biden
said in a statement
quote she is a historic and deeply
qualified choice to help lead our
administration's health efforts
end quote farther down in the article
we have her saying now not she is not
saying what she is intending to do but
she's talking about her work in
pennsylvania she says i am proud of the
work we have done as an administration
to address health equity and the work i
have done personally to raise awareness
about lgbtq equity issues
she said to which you know i ask
which is it you can't have it both ways
here we have these two things right next
to each other in an article in a single
article from washington post
are is this person going to serve all
americans
regardless of demographic marker or are
they going to be working for equity
which explicitly centers these
demographic markers and seeks redress
for differences
in outcomes which is it regardless
of demographic marker as biden says or
focusing on demographic markers as she
implies
you can't have it both ways regardless
or focused regardless or focused
i really hope it's regardless those are
his words those are biden's words
there is nothing in what i have found of
what she has said in the past
levine the new assistant health
secretary to suggest that there is going
to be in any regardless here
well also there is the fact of her
nomination
to the post which i will say um
would be striking under ordinary
circumstances
and appears to be very questionable in
the midst
of a pandemic that is bringing us to our
economic knees among
other things that this you know it is
obviously possible that she is the very
best person for that post at this moment
and just happens to be trans i don't see
any evidence to that effect
so one has to imagine that even in the
midst
of this pandemic the choice was made to
signal something about
gender identity rather than figure out
whoever the top person
for this post would have been on the
merits and that is a very disturbing
sign
and uh i'm gonna go full turf here
okay and then you're gonna riff a little
bit on on what that means
um wapo in an article from four years
ago
uh this is 2016 at the point that she
was appointed um
in pennsylvania me show this just
briefly zach meet rachel levine one of
the very few transgender public
officials in america
and this is from june 1st 2016. this is
this is while obama was still president
in this article we have um levine
being revealed as having some
traditional markers of femininity
apparently quote um she favors chunky
necklaces and earl grey tea and is in
constant motion
but later in the same article levine
does not discuss whether she took
hormones or had surgery calling it a
private medical matter
you can't actually change your sex if
you're a mammal
it's never happened you can change the
presentation
the way that you appear that is gender
in order to be welcome
in some female spaces
there is no way that self id should be
sufficient
and claiming that the actual
hormonal and surgical changes which do
not get you all the way to changing sex
but get you into a position of actually
in my mind
being transgendered if that's private
and all you have to do is wear chunky
necklaces and drink earl grey tea
to be considered female and then now
we've got this
female person as assistant health
secretary well that's you know chalk one
up to feminism
no this is this is backwards land in so
many ways and this is yet another one of
these places
where people who aren't thinking too
hard about it sort of see this go
what okay okay i guess
oh no one knows if this person is even
on
hormones of the sex they weren't born to
or has had any surgery maybe they're
just
drinking tea and wearing necklaces and
that's enough to get them called a woman
didn't know it was so easy yeah it's uh
it's an amazing feat um so you
describe yourself as having gone full
turf yeah
um turf for those of you who have been
living under a rock
um it means uh it's a it's an acronym
trans-exclusionary radical feminist
and my contention is that we can prove
that that's not actually a thing
awesome and here's how we can do it
um one says certain things in
the public sphere and this accusation
comes back you and i have both had it
hurled at us
many many times and we know many other
people who have
as well what one needs to do
in order to have that term hurled at you
is espouse a belief that's simply saying
that you are of one gender or the other
is not sufficient and that some
people will if you say that it is
sufficient if that's the standard you
legally adopt that there are those who
will game the system
and already are and
if you say those things you will be
labeled as a trans-exclusionary radical
feminist which is an accusation
akin in some circles to being called for
example
a racist right it's a it's clearly
understood to be a kind of bigotry but
here's the problem
is if those are the only things that you
need to believe in order to be in this
category then you don't need to be
trans-exclusionary right you don't need
to be radical and you don't need to be a
feminist as a matter of fact if you just
simply believed what pretty much
everybody believed 10 15 years ago
uh you'd be right there in turf land
plenty of conservatives this was your
point to me earlier plenty of
conservatives
have this same sense of like when did we
stop not understanding biology
and many conservative people would not
call themselves radical feminists right
simply traditional view of gender roles
which isn't where you and i come from
but well
[Music]
they may have a traditional role right
view of gender roles this this just
requires actually nothing about gender
roles it requires understanding biology
well right
you could come there from biology you
could come there from uh
you know just simply having a belief in
traditional roles that are you and i
would say are
antiquated but any of those things are
good enough to get you through the door
so the point is
none of the letters in the acronym are
required to be in the category it's a
special category it's like equity it's a
magic term
and in this case what that magic term is
doing
is it is standing like a buzz saw on the
side of an argument space and the idea
is you are limited to certain arguments
but if you make any of these
other arguments then we're going to
shove you into that thing we're going to
shove you into the bigot saw
yeah and at some level we have no choice
but to stare this down
turf isn't a thing just because a group
of people have decided to
equate it with bigotry and then accuse
people of it as they find
convenient doesn't make it true it
doesn't create any validity and what's
more we can tell it's invalid
because even by its own definition it
doesn't add up because there's so many
people in the category
who are none of those things yeah well i
mean i do feel like there's a way in
which we're living in an age of
legitimized epithets against women you
know turf
karen right like you know these these
are epithets
pure and simple but of course um you
know those are the two that come to mind
and there's plenty
that are hurled at people regardless of
their sex
yeah the fact that the fact that you can
be a nazi for
um for saying that equality of um
outcome is not a legitimate goal is is
rather remarkable and it acts as that
same kind of buzzsaw
yeah i agree it's a general form of
argument
um and you know there are variations on
the theme i would say
uh ibram x kendy's formulation about
there is
nothing everything is either racist or
anti-racist and therefore if you can't
say that something is anti-racist well
we know what category it's in
yeah i mean that's a very special form
of logical argument by the way
dr kennedy if you are watching and i
hope you are
we can also prove very simply in a way
that every single person who hears it
will understand
why it is the correct logical
formulation we can prove
that your contention that there is no
non-racist that there is only
racist racist and anti-racist we can
prove
that that is incorrect and i would like
to offer you
if you'd like to come on the dark horse
podcast i'd love to have you on
you can outline your position i will
outline
my challenge to it and we can see
uh which argument wins out
[Music]
you